this show is brought to you by tracker
never lose anything again with tracker
listeners to this show the Church of
What's Happening Now get a special
discount of 30 off of your entire order
go to the tracker.com
t-h-e-tracker.com and enter promo code
church that's the tracker.com promo code
Church to get 30 off of your entire
order and the show is brought to you by
audit.com go to audit.com and use
codewordchurch to get 10 off your order
of all the great optimization products
like Alpha Brain New Moon stream tech
immune and shroom Tech sport
[Music]
oh [__] oh [__] we're getting this
[__] started playing with the
Irish take it Lee
[Music]
what's up Lisa yeah you're I get I used
to love the Jungle Book when I was a kid
it comes out [__] Friday I don't
listen I don't even give a [__] the
Jungle Book Friday in 3D let me explain
we're gonna go in 3D 10 o'clock in the
morning I'm taking two of these [__]
green stars or maybe 18 of them and I'm
taking my daughter with my wife we go we
get some popcorn a hot dog
once if it goes sour we give the baby
[__] raisinette so she loses her mind
and we get out of this she does yelling
and screaming like a [__] uh a
convicted felon but if not we sit there
with it with the 3D glasses on she takes
them off and off because she doesn't
understand
oh you can't I thought it was phenomenal
I'm telling you that zootopia
if you get a chance to see it in 3D
whether you have a nephew or a niece or
not nobody's going to judge you if you
go to the 10 o'clock and sit in the
corner by yourself it's a great film and
I'm telling you this I was was it Pixar
or do you know because all these movies
now are made like when you go I used to
go late at night when I was in college
because then it's all like people it's
like 20 year olds and 30 year olds who
just like like all like Wally up all
these movies are good movies guys
they're entertaining very entertaining
but so is my guest tonight that I got a
[__] I mean it's just been a great
pleasure to meet you Dr Bliss thank you
thank you for your last name branded
yeah we can stick with bed Lisa what's
up dog yeah good I'm glad to be here now
how long are you in town for that I'm a
town for another week and then I go back
to New York for a month and then I come
back here and back and forth and back
did you do any things today yeah yeah I
saw a couple people today I wrote some
stuff you know right see people take
care of my dog
now let everybody know what you do so um
I'm founder of the breathing class which
is exactly what it sounds like I've
always gotten yelled at uh about
changing the name you know get a name
like Lululemon why don't you get a name
like uh spin classes like uh pure yoga
and I can't it's the breathing class
that's what it is I teach people to
breathe so I'm a clinical psychologist
from a million years ago and I switched
over to teach people breathing
and uh whether it's endurance for sports
or stress reduction it works I love
doing it and and that's what I do no
yeah
when you say you work with somebody for
an endurance I'm uh
I'm a track runner I'm young you know 32
I want to run the Iron Man whatever
what kind of how much work goes in on
the other side okay well 30 it's not
like you're gonna touch them
and do three because see I've heard this
[__] before like somebody's thumb
there's a guy in Burbank you go down
there and he touches your lungs and you
get endurance to me that sounds [__]
far-fetched no because they believe that
the the rib cage is attached to the to
the lung the lung won't expand and I
heard that I'm like something don't
sound right there and I heard that about
a year ago I was like that that's not
gonna work no how long would a person
have to work to increase their endurance
with your principles okay well let's
think about first of all is that if
you're 32
um you your lung capacity actually grows
until you're 29. so you've already
started to Plateau as far as your
breathing at 32 it's not like you're
going to get better your breathing's
going to get better it's actually going
to get worse so you need to start doing
breathing exercises I'd say you can make
a change if you're super motivated
within a week definitely within two so
I've seen people get the exercises do
them crazy do them uh with like
incredible motivation and focus and
change their endurance within a week 10
days
absolutely you can do that I can't touch
your chest and have it happen in a
couple seconds definitely not but I
don't know about that no I read
somewhere where you worked in Jacques
Cousteau yeah I did work with Jessica
yeah and so in New York and and then I
got moved over to the office in Paris it
was great I mean hey I wasn't on the
boat I wasn't on the boat but I was a
big Cousteau fan before I mean
wow so no I know a lot I mean I loved
marine life beforehand and my French was
uh my second major so I wanted a job
with Jacques Cousteau that had anything
to do with animals and and water and you
know even though I was in New York I
didn't get to go on the boat but he was
around his family was around it was a
really great experience your resume is
just
when it comes to breathing you like the
jecon
and it's very smart I love that about
people I hate people who show up and say
well over at Harvard I specialize in
this and this is how it is and
somebody's gonna say listen I read this
journal and this and this and this and
this is what I took you from each person
this is like what kind of and in my
world they call us a synopsis what's the
other word an educated guess in a way
but a proven guest yeah I could tell by
your confidence yeah we had an email and
then you called me and you told me to do
this and we tried to connect them on a
private level and I was always busy
because it was pilot season and then I
saw that you were doing a seminar and I
just signed up without calling I was
just excited I was in town the same week
you were there you know and uh
what really made me want to put you on
the podcast and what really was your
call to me on Sunday it was distressing
but not fatal you know the family we
could work on my lung power and do all
these things
but it really touched me that there's
still people who believe in customer
service who call oh yeah and I'll send
you stuff afterward and we'll call again
and keep in touch you you know called me
yesterday Anthony Harlock
it was Anthony because it was great to
see you boom I'm in yeah that's the
school of thought I was raised from you
know like I was gonna call you Monday
I'm not gonna close my mud's day you
didn't give a [__]
I did great and that's how I I work with
people is that
um if you're motivated and you want to
get better or you're motivated and you
want to get you know rid of your
whatever medical problem you have or you
better endurance if you're into this if
you want to you know work with me I'm
excited about it I love people who want
to change and want to get better and um
I will call you I will remind you
um it's tough love because I'm gonna say
things you may not like but I'll say
things that no other doctor has ever
told you before because a lot of doctors
will pussyfoot around they'll say well I
don't want to tell my patient this
because then I'll have them here for
another hour and they'll be calling and
I'm just going to write the script but
um no I I everything about you liable
then I'm liable if I tell there's
something going on inside with me yeah I
know there is this it's it's not lung
cancer nothing like that but you know I
go to acupuncture I go to the heart
doctor he does all the [__] inks
through the heart and all that stuff the
problem uh who oh you were talking about
you like you should have been on some
type of oxygen therapy when I go to the
sleep apnea doctor the first thing they
do to me is I blow in some [__] bugle
yeah
you did the bugle in my class and I know
it's [__] terrible because I can't
even finish it it's like a [__]
you know it doesn't take a genius I'm no
med school student but I know it's not
good the lady walks away and nobody says
dick to me yeah they come back and they
ask me when I'm doing a sleep study
okay what I say to you I said I'm
already done the sleep study what the
[__] am I going to go back in and get
tortured for they put a masking and then
turn the ad down to two and watch you
squirm around like [__] Hannibal like
that at the end like they electrocuted
May [__] you well that was kind of my
question it sounds like a silly question
but why is breathing so important okay
you know when I have to say the short
version of that it's the Cornerstone of
your health so if you're not breathing
well you can do everything after that
it's just not going to work as well so
it's Ox it's cell fuel it fuels your
entire body and it's what your brain
works on what your organs work on what
your muscles work on think about it
everything you do is to get more oxygen
in your body when you take supplements
you know you're working out all the
things that you do are so that you can
use the oxygen better and get more
oxygen in your body so why not actually
just breathe better I mean doing all the
other stuff is good too but just start
with breathing better it sounds a lot a
lot of what Joey talks about on the show
is uh
like getting to the root of the problem
really like just getting to this the
most simple step so you can it's like
when people do like for a podcast
they'll do weird stuff that you don't
really need to do like weird videos or
whatever
and before you can work out I guess you
have to be able to breathe like before
you can do any of that it's very cut to
the chase
um and that's my Mo even as a therapist
because I was a therapist for 25 years I
was very cut to the chase I was I used
to give people homework it was very
Dynamic I didn't sit back and go okay
well make an appointment with me you
know four times a week for 10 years that
was not my I mean a lot of people wanted
that and needed that it's not my the way
I work it needs to be dynamic you need
to do your homework I will love you I
will call you I'll do anything you need
to get your goals done but you got to
work with me it's very Dynamic and and
you see change immediately so um so
that's why I mean your body needs oxygen
but I also I mean it needs a balance of
oxygen if I'm going to be more specific
it's that more and more and more oxygen
isn't better it's the combination of of
having a balance of carbon dioxide and
oxygen in your body and using the right
muscles which is what Joey learned about
what muscles you have in your body that
help you breathe better and he's making
those strong so yeah I did the twist
today yeah
nice I did the Kettlebell on my stomach
with the breathing electronic your belly
button to hit the back yeah I read
another chapter
I just uh
I gotta tell you it's sad
because that was my forte growing up
that I could
you know me and these girls Kathy Moran
leave a [__] Geeks in the eighth
grade
yeah I went around the corner and smoked
pot with the long-haired kids once
but you know what my I loved I wanted to
get really good at basketball
so I knew in the fourth quarter what do
you need [__] endurance okay and I
would sit against a wall and work on my
muscles to get tight in the eighth grade
and seventh grade but she was a track
runner in the high school they were
older than I was her and her girlfriends
and I would go to them and say dog I
don't know nothing about running
and then we go okay just come to the
height and we go to McKinley first and
they had like a hundred yard
concrete [__] platform you went to my
grammar school yeah yeah and her and I
would walk out 40 yards and we'd do 40
yard Sprints and another kid Poncho
Cuban kids stole the the hurdles and I
tried to hurdles and I was really good
at them and you know I started playing
basketball when I was a freshman I could
hold on to the rim and I was two inches
away from dunking and I could run and I
remember running from you know I come
from the second hilliest town in the
country I come from North Bergen New
Jersey on paper look it up on you it's
the second hilliest Town behind San
Francisco when I first moved to North
Bergen the cemetery is on the bottom of
the hill so when it would rain the
graves would wash out they just [__]
fixed that maybe maybe what happened
like with the bottom of 46th Street a
casket was floating down no a [__]
tuxedo with a half a skeleton that's
what down your [__] block and then
they had to get engineering and redo it
back because the cemetery would wash out
you know a cemetery is [__] old so
yeah that's terrifying me and this
[__] me and these girls would run up
like we'd walk up the first Hill I mean
lightly jog the second Hill and we go
from [__] no we'd go from 39th Street
you know on a light jog all the way to
88th Hudson County Parking and run
around the lake 18 times and then run
back home and then 94 what is 94 put me
31 years old when I was 30. they used to
have this bike trail in North Bergen
that you rode up Boulevard East
overlooking New York City skyline so
there you are riding up you go to the
you go all the way to [__] the George
Washington Bridge and then you ride
across on the bike and then you go all
the way down the West Side Highway
to the ferry and then you take the ferry
across that's your only breather and
then when you get to the other side at
one of those ports if you look up the
Weehawken there's stairs that are
attached to the mountain Lee and it's
just attached and it's endless you see
you see elevators
but then you see these stairs that go up
so me and these gorillas used to grab
our bicycles hold the bicycles and run
up those [__] stairs like gorillas to
the top I never huffed I never puffed
who knew what the [__] happened
my endurance was always money 30 years
20 years of doing cocaine your endurance
got to count for something you know what
I'm saying that's a lot of endurance
overnight
I smoke cigarettes for a few years you
know not early on but later on in my
life and I stopped I'll tell you what
was [__] me up the vapor pens
those little Vapor things I think they
[__] you up a little bit my breathing
was off after that
but the anxiety started two years ago
after an ear infection I never had that
if I can't get air anxiety ever ever
ever before in my life
but your body's pissed when you said you
know that something's wrong with your
body because that's most people that
come to me they'll come with me to me
for specific reasons but then I get that
person who goes I know something's wrong
but I don't know what and they usually
touch their chest I know like I know
intuitively something is not right
inside I've got tons of prescriptions
I've got doctors I've got appointments
but something isn't right and I don't
think that I'm get it's getting
addressed with my appointments so you're
gonna get better you're definitely gonna
I you may not do those stairs with the
with the bike because that sounds crazy
but we're definitely you're gonna get
better because like I said it's the
Cornerstone of your health so we're
going to see your blood pressure come
down everything everything's gonna get
better my blood pressure's really come
down
the last couple years I think my health
and fitness I mean
it's very deceiving what's going on with
my body sometimes because I've always
been a big boned not fat but just a
thick dude and once I added weights in
my regimen it really like there's
this night's when I'm sleeping and I'm
gonna roll over and I feel my leg and I
don't know whose leg it is because
that's how different my body has got
like it's hard now you know
I love all this [__] I'm doing now but
when it comes to my breathing and
something you said something at the
seminar you said something happened
till this day I don't know what happened
because I was fine I swam when I went
back to the Y when I got really heavy I
started when I was 4 18 I walked into I
did a commercial at
which would you know to do the dude
who's got Parkinson's the boxing coach
right here in Hollywood we're Pacquiao
trains wild card okay I did a commercial
there and I met a guy named macafoli and
during the thing macafoli as I sell you
in a movie you were very funny and he
goes I gotta be honest with you man
you could be funny for a long time you
should lose some weight why don't you
come to the gym and throw some minutes
with me I'll train you for a while even
if it's for free just to get you started
I had nothing to lose I was 400 [__]
pounds so I started going over there
and I couldn't believe how hard I was
working and how slow it took the weight
to come off
and I was still drinking three or four
cans of [__] Coke every day you know
and finally I read an article but no
matter how much you exercise you still
need to control your diet your diet's
number one thing you know
and I kept going but at that time
I used to have to wear two pair
underwear I was thinking about you to
give you more history because when I
couldn't breathe I'd pee my pants my
pants couldn't my breathing couldn't
control my little dick anime and
breathing at the same time is that a
common thing because you're like you
don't seem surprised you know what I'm a
you know my I did 25 years of therapy
people you gotta say something really
crazy to get me to blush or think it's
not so I've heard some crazy no no I
didn't say it again
has she ever heard it before that's what
I was asking yeah no no so you know what
so um your pelvic floor and we did this
in class we talked about your pelvic
floor it's the 20 muscles on the bottom
of your body it's connected to your
diaphragm your thoracic diaphragm like
those two things remember we did this in
class where here's your body right so
your pelvic diaphragm is down here your
thoracic diaphragm is up on top so
they're related so that your breathing
had something to do with your pelvic
floor with that happening makes perfect
sense to me yeah everything's gonna get
stronger
everything's going to get stronger we
can go back to one pair of underwear for
sure
this was wild I'd go the round would be
over and he'd say go in your in your
corner
and I would feel the pee going out of my
van there's nothing I can do yeah I
wasn't gonna make the bathroom
if I walk to the bathroom and I have a
heart attack like by trying to hold a
pee at the same time and have a heart
attack when did that start that started
when I hit 418 because when I was
shooting along a shot I didn't have
those problems but when I was shooting
along this yard believe it or not when I
was in Albuquerque they gave me oxygen
the doctor of the team said come here
for a second I'm going to give you
honest I'm thinking about all these
things just so you know
but I'm also thinking about switching
sleep apnea doctors now that you also
told me that because after they look at
that they should make some type of
recession your numbers were really low
really low really low I know I can't
blow like a [__] candle out we did an
exercise with our fingers yeah
oh look at that
he's breathing perfectly now because
I've been doing a thousand of these
[__] I'm watching him now that's so
weird because it's so weird because
sometimes you lose the focus and you're
sucking him and you sucking yeah
so you really really want to focus but I
when I read your book it says repeat
repeat and you'll cause the new habit
break from zero to fifty what happens
because I have a three-year-old
and when you look at Mercy from the side
she looks like a fat little [__] but
when you look at her straight ahead
she's tiny long and skin limp and that's
because when she watches TV ah
yeah she's breathing she's breathing
right she's breathing so you made a
point that we breathe normally two or
five what happened and then okay so what
happens five years old so she and her
little belly go to school right cute
little belly she doesn't know you know
she's just happy to be a little kid go
to bed go to school and what happens
somebody pokes her in the bell and goes
fatty right because kids are mean
because kids are mean so all of a sudden
she comes home she thinks she's fat and
that starts Decades of sucking in your
gut Decades of like sucking in your gut
so that you feel or you look skinnier
and then we're told that that makes you
stronger too and that doesn't make you
stronger really bracing your belly does
not make you stronger inhaling letting
it go and actually working your abs and
squeezing on the exhale that makes you
stronger but just bracing your middle
doesn't so other things that happens you
start sitting because Americans sit how
many hours a day do you think Americans
sit
all day yeah pretty much all day how
many hours at least
10 12 13 to 16 hours a day but that's
when you factor in the drive and yeah
the lunch is you know most people sit at
a desk I'll tell you what I I can't lie
to you I forgot the number one because
you mentioned yeah and yeah Dad did
something when I stood yeah I just
started little things man because you
know I fly I fly five hours one [__]
way if you don't think I get up and
stretch my calves and when I sit down my
you know acupuncture said uh they call
the cap the the heart of the leg the
second pump so instead of moving around
sometimes I just do leg lifts at my seat
good to keep the blood going so you
don't get that [__] way you know you get
like the blood clot or whatever the [__]
it is so uh it's crazy I just found out
recently in the past couple years that
girls suck in like I've always been
chubby but I've never once sucked in all
like I can imagine sucking in all day
but then again think about it especially
little girls you start wearing clothes
and they're tighter you start wearing
compression garments you have like you
know little sports bra Sprouts sports
bras will squeeze the hell out of you
you know and exactly where you want to
be opening up and breathing so then
we're told you know the posture you tell
somebody to sit up straight the first
thing they do is they pull in their gut
if you get injured and I mean with
sports now kids get injured or you fall
off your skateboard or sled you get hit
in the middle of your body you don't
want to take a deep breath it hurts
there and then you look at everybody
around you and you're a little kid and
they're raising their shoulders when
they breathe so you think that's the
right way to breathe so all of a sudden
you're sucking in your little gut and
you're breathing like this like your
parents do unless you stop them and you
teach them is he take a deep breath like
Mom and Dad and you show them the right
way to breathe so which is through the
middle of your body pretty much from
your armpits to your to your pelvis is
where you should be breathing from but
none of this up and down with your
shoulders ah
yeah
did I want to see that inhale and exhale
again that was good that made me happy
yeah I'm trying I'm trying I gotta tell
you his flexibility I was amazed
three hours you sat there you put some
flexibility holy even when I was really
heavy I always stretched that night yeah
there's guilt over me and I was always
involved in martial arts and stretching
and then
my wife took me to yoga a few times and
I really enjoyed like the uh
like the downward dog yeah I don't know
dogs and the child's pose and then the
one the cat Cloud yeah
and that's what I've been doing for the
breathing
and I enjoy a good stretch in fact I was
me and my wife made like the same
commitment she's been over at her yoga
place for five months she she went and
bought 10 passes and just she always had
a problem with the Y and then one of her
girlfriends took it to another place and
that place was too [__] my wife's
from Tennessee she don't buy into the
[Applause]
and at first when I started dating it
kind of bothered me about it because
some of the [__] to me is interesting
but some of this [__] is just so out
there it's just white people trying to
be [__] crazy you know and at the Y
there was a little click of that there
was this little like Japanese girl very
cute and she'd go in there you know with
a perfect little body she was 22 filthy
feet the feet were always filthy like
Way Beyond the dirty like the dirt has
stuck onto her feet
because she did yoga dances where a
bunch of people played Bongos where they
do the line dance the line the conga
line and they talk to the angels while
they do downward dog and [__] that my
wife will not tolerate
you know that one there's no woo in my
class there's a little bit of woo you
know at the end we do a meditation no no
that was great that was great yeah and
yoga is called shavasana there we go
yeah when I try to do that at home when
I laid down I go this is just shavasana
while I move my hips and breathe and
exhale yeah instead of just laying there
like a [__] mummy it was funny
because I used to go to a German listen
we used to go to yoga together me and my
wife before she got knocked up I got
divorced when I was young and it
bothered me and I gotten divorced it
really bothered me because that's the
most simple thing as a relationship how
can you [__] The Voice somebody what
the [__] is wrong with Americans you
know what I'm saying that is the
simplest form of friendship is is uh so
I got so when you do common you get lost
sometimes you know not that you get lost
but you forget where you stand even as
and I didn't want to lose Terry so I'd
pick her up and we'd run home on
Tuesdays and we'd go to yoga together
but our favorite yoga class
which I went just to get high and giggle
you had to be a monster it was called
Power Yoga
on Tuesdays and it was taught by a
German chick and I mean when I tell
German this chick was Hitler's niece and
she never lost the accent so she would
go
shavazana
like I don't even do I don't even give
it justice she did it very Germany yeah
I can't we me and my wife would leave
they're like I'd be [__] crushed
Christ she'd have me picking up my leg
and Joey you could do this one more sun
salutation down up because I'll lose a
hundred pounds you come to my class and
she thought somewhere else like she
taught like in Venice like three days
she goes if you come to my class and
read this twice a week I'll have you 100
pounds of lighter and she would say I'll
have your breathing restructured and
I'll have that fat falling right off you
and I used to looking like you're crazy
so me and my wife used to call it Joe
the German
and after a while I'm like I can't go to
Joe the German no more though she
[__] kills me but she was a big
stickman on shivasa
she really stressed the breathing and
she walked around and she made the
adjustments and I love the stuff to the
things and yeah yeah well how often do
we really pause and just relax a little
bit we don't we don't really pause and
do nothing thing and really do nothing
it doesn't happen you're always checking
your phone or going somewhere or coming
back or worrying about something or
regretting something just really doing
nothing for a couple seconds good for
you
I have been since this little thing I
was little it would concern me
as soon as I went to jiu jitsu the first
time and did a hip escape and tried to
jiu jitsu eyes I went home mortified
like and then I tried to get high and go
to class like I get high to do anything
one time went to jiu jitsu class I
thought I thought I was dead I thought I
was dead I had to go outside and breathe
and take my ghee top off between the
Heat because you got to get used to that
heat that heat at first and I'm a hot
dude you know what I'm saying I go to
the doctor and the chicken takes my
blood pressure goes you're a hot [__]
dude like you're hot blooded Cuban dog I
wake up at 190 over 180. you know what
I'm saying I'm one of those
[__] I dream about yelling and
screaming and jumping up and down and
somebody stealing my [__] chocolate
cake or something like that I don't
[__] know I have some crazy dreams
too I have some really like I don't have
dreams
I just now it's weird the Alpha Brain
will give you a vivid dream
uh whenever I go on an Alpha Brain cycle
I'll get my dreams I'll get like they
come back in color yeah but I tell you
what I I know I talk in my sleep with
the [__] Sleep Apnea mask on because
my wife tells me she'll tell me you're
having a conversation with the
Mastermind I just heard a bunch of
[__] mumbling stumbles and then but I
know you talk Spanish
I always talk Spanish in my dreams so
I'm dreaming about something when I was
a kid always with my mother talking with
my father
an uncle I always dream the Spanish so
this This concerns me because one of the
things that happens is you talk a lot
you talk for your job you talk in
between your job and wherever you're
going and coming from and now you're I'm
hearing that you talk in your sleep
poor Terrace
she hits me with this like three times a
year
one thing about me is that when I first
moved to LA I didn't say no
and by 2004
I wasn't suicidal but I was
I didn't have a life I didn't have you
know I was with my wife from 2000
to probably 2003 I didn't see around the
holiday
I didn't believe in it I'm trying to go
after a dream here you know I'm saying
you want to get married and get mushy
well let's do this first and then we'll
[__] get married but who wants to get
married to [__] struggle all that
goddamn life
who the [__] wants to do this [__] yeah
we'll we'll go with this ain't no
[__] Bon Jovi song [__] it's 2016.
you know it's 269 the least [__]
and that's with zero down you know what
I'm talking about you know we bought
what's that Bon Jovi song that's great I
believe in that too
but you got to work you know what I'm
saying listen man
but then I thought back about because I
was looking at it as a person that
didn't have a family I did have a family
she was my family I looked at as a Cuban
single dude who didn't have parents or
an uncle [__] it I'm not gonna sit at
home I might as well go to Houston and
try to make a little money and stuff
and then when I I go I've been dating
this girl for so long and living with it
I gotta start spending more time with
her so I started spending all days with
stuff like that and since like 2005 I
really appreciate my time because I know
how fast Hollywood could be I could be
said I'm totally a thousand times I go
Lee I could be sitting here with you
making plans and all of a sudden I've
got a call they come up with a new TV
show
and it's gonna happen it's gonna happen
later one day I'm recording you know I I
booked some show
and I gotta work [__] six days a week
and I gotta be there at six in the
morning I'm working till six at night
they don't want to come and [__] talk
to you
when I go home at night it's not about
me and my wife I keep listen my wife is
white real wife from Tennessee you get
her started you ain't gonna shut her up
you know what I'm saying you know if I
tell a story about my uncle stabbing a
dude she'll tell me a story about one
time Ernest is to kill the fly
and they won't [__] end in this
family it won't [__] end there's a
big fly yeah it won't end so I don't try
to entice my wife too much and once I
entice her I pray for the [__] phone
to ring you understand me once she
starts going off the other day she
brought my wife's smart man and
sometimes I get myself in a [__] well
and she won't shut the [__] up don't get
it started on politics she'll start
torching with the super delegates and
[__] you're praying for that [__]
phone to ring you're sitting there
please somebody [__] called Already
Lord please I don't give a [__] if it's
a wrong number if that sound like
to cancel this [__] conversation
so I try to keep it light at the house
and I really like the two hours before I
get up in the morning because I spend
two hours by myself
I don't say two [__] words
I sit there without the TV on I put a
notebook I get coffee I smoke a couple
of salutes I listen to my heart pound
now I breathe so now I got the chair and
I just do my little hip things in the
chair
can you hear your heartbeat though
no I hate it you eat that [__] star
you'll hear it pounding in your head
like one of those Disney no you can hear
it yeah okay good because I got a breath
for you to practice that yeah
it's with you okay
I got the advanced stuff to give you
because you're now you went through the
beginner you're in advance now let me
ask you this okay just for people
how does this help with blood pressure
oh it's direct blood pressure is
actually the the medical condition that
has the most research behind it when it
comes to breathing the most
lots of other things not as much there
are studies and some don't have studies
yet and I'll tell you it's my you know
medical Intuition or whatever but blood
pressure there is a lot of science that
shows you control your breathing you
take a breath where it's helping your
parasympathetic where it's helping that
calming breath and your blood pressure
will come down it's con it's intimately
connected in fact you can't breathe with
that lower body breath without your
blood pressure being affected and if you
actually want to do the opposite when I
work with actors and they want to get
upset and they want to get more and
wouldn't to whatever upset state they're
in depending on their role they have to
breathe with an upper body breath and
their blood pressure will go up their
heart rate will go up their cortisol
will go up yeah
so it's completely connected which is
wild that's why I actually like working
with blood pressure patients because you
can see your blood pressure come down
and you can keep it down so all of a
sudden you start realizing I actually
have a lot of control over my body and
we actually talked about this is that it
sounds like I'm giving you bad news that
you're in trouble but the good news is
that you're in trouble but your
breathing is going to change things and
you have ultimate control over your
breathing none of your doctors do none
of the prescriptions do you can change
your breathing so your blood pressure is
actually something that we're going to
watch go down pretty quickly I've been
doing any exercises
and you have to really think and control
yourself and control your breathing
but what I found to be the most
interesting how is uh
you
you told me to focus on the exhales yeah
but
you tense up like I still tense up to
control everything still you know I
still tense up
but then also in your mind goes Stop
Dancing
and all of a sudden now you're breathing
a little easier and I know that it's
like karate it's like anything else that
you learn single movements
they always want you to over exaggerate
them so the repetition and then in your
book I also read repeat repeat so I know
that right now I'm just over
exaggerating you know I know I'm doing a
belly workout with this you are yeah I
wake up the next day a little bit I was
sore the Sunday after the seminar
and what did I do Sunday I think I did
kettlebell Sunday
Monday I had a busy day
Tuesday I went to jiu jitsu and today I
went to jiu jitsu you're Maniac that's
what I did that's good and now I got no
option I gotta go to Jujitsu tomorrow
because it's there the opportunity is
there and that's the commitment I'm
cheap because my fear was getting on my
back but that fear being on my back
stand from sleep apnea I pushed my sleep
apnea to the [__] health
and you know when I and and we've
discussed sleep apnea on the show before
you have no idea what it is to to you
have no ideally once that sleep apnea
comes you have no [__] Landing people
kept telling me I had it like I don't I
never woke up choking but I was a huge
snore so people always told me I should
go get checked out what is what is your
girlfriend say nothing no I don't no she
used to have to wear earplugs well you
lost a lot of weight yeah you lost a lot
of weight so so the weight went down so
that was the same thing at 4 18 you
couldn't sleep Three Doors Down you
couldn't sleep Three Doors Down my poor
wife was well if you think about exactly
what that is so that noise is that
there's something in the way there's
there's tissue you know fat fat the
[__] tubes don't say it's [__] fat
are you kidding you know and it's weight
you know that's the other thing I factor
in like when I first went to jiu jitsu I
got so [__] discouraged and I went
home and I felt really bad and I go whoa
wait a second first of all this isn't me
that's number one I don't get
discouraged I'm not good at [__]
mechanics and I'm not good at fixing a
computer but that's never been my
aptitude God never gave me that aptitude
when I was a kid and I got a flat tire
I drew the bike away and I bought
another one for 14.95 okay I sold that
one for eight just of course I was too
lazy to change a flat because I wasn't
good at it I could never get the [__]
thing in the tire and take it out and
then [__] sink the thing I didn't
have the patience for it that's why I
love a Camaro but who's gonna fix it you
you're gonna come over and fix my Camaro
to be a car Enthusiast you gotta know
what the [__] you're doing but I do know
different things
and I like different martial arts I look
at all that for most people most people
look at a martial arts like that as a
combat Marshall oh look at it like that
I look at this two guys it's a chess
game
with your mind but your body's in the
way
and you the guy who gets best is the guy
that can move his body
without moving his body around you
that's all Jiu Jitsu is
if you look at all the really good guys
they don't even break a sweat
or breathe hard Breathe hard
you mean why you're fighting them
they're fighting nobody they're just
waiting on your moves and controlling
your moves and you know it's so
interesting so I didn't like that I was
scared of doing something I [__] hate
that [__] when I'm scared I'm [__]
pissed of something you know it's like
when I have to go give blood like
tomorrow because I got nothing on the
cards really except for 10 o'clock
I gotta go over to this [__] place
and give them an allergy test the lady
told me it's one drop of blood
it's pissing me off but I get up like
with a Cuban and I'm going down there
right now I gotta bring my iPod I can't
smoke dope
and I go down and get my allergy test
but that's the same way I felt about Jiu
Jitsu being on my back because I kept
getting at the end my sleep apnea
was getting to the point that I would
wake up and just run and stand up and
just go
what the [__] was that like I didn't
know what it was like I wasn't just
waking up and looking around and going
boy that was a that was a piece of
chicken in my throat no I was running up
out of the bed going
and I hope you know what it's like in a
hotel room where you wake up
and you don't know where you are and you
can't breathe you know the anxiety I
used to get and then I got help for the
breathing for the sleep apnea
but towards the end of the cocaine and
the sleep apnea I started getting
anxiety
not the beliefs and it wasn't
it was from not breathing I would go on
planes and my mind would take off and go
what if
what if the plane chasing your head hits
the glass
will you bleed what are you gonna run
what are you going to run 10. Dr Belize
my [__] brain would take over and it
wouldn't stop till I just breathe
but again I was a mouth breather so what
am I putting in my body on my monoxide
right especially in an airplane in a
[__] airplane so this is sending me
into a [__] state of and I got
arrested twice and let go because I
would tell them get me off the [__]
plane yeah I don't want no [__] give
me you listen get me off the phone
complain I start to karate chop
[__] in the neck
so they got to talk to me and they make
my wife come down and [__]
then they put me on pills I got off the
pills and I just went right to Reef for
an acupuncture and it went away and I
worked on
my weight and I dropped 100 pounds
and that took that anxiety so I walked
into Jiu Jitsu and they gave it back to
me again I were times before I would
drive to Jiu-Jitsu on the drive there oh
my God my heart at the light
would be Plumping up a storm
and then as soon as I touch a dude I
would have to tap just from the fear and
the anxiety and the lack of oxygen I
just have to tap
I want them when you go to the doctor
tomorrow to look at your CO2
because I can tell you that one of the
things is that you have too much carbon
dioxide in your body you have too much
in your body so how do you get too much
carbine that saying you're not getting
it out so how do you get it out so
you're learning how to Exhale which
exactly once your exhale gets better
it'll even out
so you could have a machine but I would
rather you do you can do it yourself
it's just that exhale because if you
have a big belly to Exhale all the way
out takes a lot of effort so you have
too much that's too much in there I had
um I had a a guy actually was a friend
on Facebook I never really met him but
he would wake up and he would almost be
psychotic he'd have like some PTSD stuff
he was a vet happen and once they took
him to the hospital and they looked at
his CO2 and it was super high
super high so that's what happened is
that he had too much in his body so he
was it was toxic to his body so I can
tell you because of the belly and you're
going to get rid of that belly and
you're going to Exhale and your whole
body will squeeze so watch yourself when
you cough because I just watched you
cough and you look at that see how you
cough you cough perfectly which believe
me not everybody coughs right but that's
a good cough when you cough your belly
squeezes because it's trying to get air
out of your body right beautiful that's
exactly what I want you to do with the
breathing is exhale all the way out does
that make sense that like your belly's
in the way of the exhale it does make
sense and now what do people do
because it's actually really crazy that
you're here today yeah I I my dad loves
everything and he he was watching and I
cough a lot and like every time I get a
cold now I get like bronchitis yeah so
if I if like okay if I wanna explore
more of this yeah how do we like who do
we con like contact you or like who do
we get
it's me
or actually he's getting kind of an
expert so
after Saturday uh you may have him right
next to you but uh but it's your exhale
you two with your exhale let me see you
cough
foreign
see how your coughs better
yeah what did I do wrong yeah so go
ahead cough
a little bit right so I want your exhale
to be really big exhale really big
exhale so go ahead and exhale
okay and now give me an inhale
and exhale
now just regular exhale no cough yeah
see there's nothing happening yo she'll
you will teach you okay but it's all up
here again and this up here that's a
stress breath and there's no lungs up
there so pretty much what Lee's doing is
that on the inhale he's picking up his
shoulders and on the exhale he's putting
his shoulders down so you're breathing
with your shoulders pretty much which
means your diaphragm is sitting right
there in the middle of your body doing
nothing I also have a problem that
everyone yells at me when I do
kettlebells and I stop breathing when
I'm doing the elbows yeah how do I fix
that uh well you need you know when you
swing it you kettlebells need the breath
like incredibly you can't
you cannot breathe you cannot so pretty
much the rule is exhale on effort
whatever you're doing at the gym when
you're making an effort when you're
pushing or pulling or doing the
Kettlebell the effortful part of it you
should be exhaling and that's going to
make it actually easier to lift more
weight and it does and I'm trying it's
something I have to focus on because
while I'm doing it I'll Focus too much
on the act of doing and I people will be
like breathe breathe yep but they should
say exhale exhale because you're already
in an inhale you're kind of in a
constant inhale I need you to Exhale
it's a similar thing actually
similar
do you think the fat shocks our body of
the lungs well the extreme weight the
weight definitely the cortisol goes up
but your body gets toxic so it's
inflamed and that's why you have the
nose stuff going on is that the
inflammation in your body from the
weight everything catapults from there
so now you're fixing it from the bottom
up now that you're breathing from the
bottom up your body's less acidic
because we actually we we did this
acidity right so we're going to get
yours to be better and yours is better
when you breed after class the other day
you're at 6.8 so you actually got the
inside of your body to be healthier by
the end of class your acidity changed
significantly to the end of class
and that just makes a huge difference so
I'm on a mission with you I want a
mission I know you are which is why I'm
excited I did like I said I did the
exercise thing that was interesting that
I missed well I didn't remember it from
the seminar was the ball on your lap and
stretching your back I did that one
today you know I did the side you know
uh Pentecostal stretches yeah going down
exhaling them back up I did it on both
sides I did the Kettlebell like I said
earlier I love that uh I did the one
with
just breathing yeah
I did a little bit of rock and roll and
that one's good because I'm just that
works I'm keeping my shoulders down good
so I just go out yeah we did some
interesting stuff where you breathe and
then you take another breath and put
your shoulders back yeah and then let it
all out that one I didn't mess with
because I was catching myself doing the
wrong exercise that's perfect I was
catching myself doing the wrong form you
know exactly what I was doing I was
using my shoulders up instead of sucking
and then going back you know what I'm
saying so all these are from their some
of them are from yoga some of the
exercises from yoga some are from
martial arts like pretty much the
Systema Russian Special Operations stuff
um and other martial arts and some of
them are from free diving and surfing
um so it's kind of a mix of different
exercises from all different sports
including Western pulmonary health and
all the all the numbers that we took in
the beginning now do you do the seminar
across the country schools or just all
different schools yeah la and I move all
over I move all over I do some I do the
Department of Justice in San Diego and I
do the DEA in New York actually yeah and
a lot of Jiu Jitsu schools across the
country
I what do I have coming up
um
I've got a couple corporations I got
some private patients
um no I've learned about you
yeah
so let's pretend I'm a school right now
in San Antonio Texas and I want to bring
you down for a Saturday how would they
get a hold they you know on the website
or uh on the website and actually if you
just put in Dr bellissa or breathing
you'll always get a phone number or an
email so Dr bellissa gmail.com
uh
d-r-b-e-l-i-s-a gmail.com or there's a
phone number up there as well six four
six two fifty sixty three ninety yeah
when I went to your seminaria that you
handed me a book that's your a book and
you have a couple books out I got a
couple yeah and are they all on the
topic of breathing no they're not
because
um all within psychology I've had a
million different jobs so one of the
jobs I had along the way was being the
sex and health expert at Men's Fitness
magazine
so I have a couple books out there about
relationships about relationships yeah
not that that's one of my strengths as
you asked me before before coming on the
podcast yeah very attractive I like your
style you're very warm I was just I
didn't know what Nick was made Serbian
we got Serbian and Cuban yeah okay yeah
I wasn't trying that yeah be
disrespectful not at all I want to ask
you a question very interesting question
that I mentioned this before on the show
so I have no embarrassment here we're
talking his family and
I'm sure that not too many people have
asked you this let's get it out of the
way
breathing and sex
good topic great topic I'm not trying to
be horny before I said something off
color I was talking to Lee and I didn't
mean it towards you you know I love you
and respect that's a little dick but I
didn't say anything I just said it's the
truth you know we're talking here I
consider you like family yeah when I
meet Cuban people yeah
um how I I test human people as I say a
couple things years ago when I first got
that way I met this dude in an audition
and he was Cuban from Miami and we spoke
and I go listen I do this show we're at
The Comedy Store come on down you know I
talk about my family on stage at the end
they ran out of there like a month later
I called again because he was never that
insulted and never been so ashamed to be
Cuban that he heard Union City you know
he was a Cuban from Michigan and the
little Community was not like them so
I've always been very listen man I went
to another Cuban's house with a bunch of
other Cubans and a Cuban played Mambo
music and the parents went
but [__] manners
like and then we found LA there was for
racist motives whatever but you know
Cubans are [__] weird people so yeah
but for me with Cubans I'm too old to
dick around so I push an envelope one
more day you were very sweet and uh sex
and breathing sex and breathing well
first of all you know what
um I'm not gonna get I have thick skin
and um and I like I like when people are
real you know I like when people are
real so uh and I had this this sex and
health background so I was a sexpert for
a while and uh nothing you know and a
psychologist for a while working with
all kinds of people so any weird
question I love the weird well you said
something very interesting and let's
break it out in the [__] open yeah
I don't want to leave the girl outside
with the dog that much it's not that
it's a bad neighborhood so we'll go like
15 moments but this is a very
interesting question
Okay so
before
when I was a young kid I was spooked
into Catholic religion you know spooked
and you spooked about sex and your
sexuality and you don't talk about it
and everything I Learned was at the
[__] ball you know what I'm saying
and I went to a few movies with some
Godfathers with my godfather Ted or
whatever and
I was always ashamed I don't know and
yeah you know when you get to be high
school you mess around with people you
get pressed you finger somebody whatever
I was never I never just even thought
about sex or nothing like that and then
the sun before my mom that I met this
little dirty white chick and we used to
play around and [__] because I used to
drive with this other girl in grammar
school and I was a good dry hump I could
drive up for two or three hours you know
what I'm saying I could try him to a
whole side of this song
so her and I broke up [__] evolves and
then there were [__] family again I
guarante the other guys have these
problems and I'm telling you you said
some things that the other day I was in
the bathroom reading and I go wait a
second she's [__] sharp
so
um
man this girl Fooled Around and listen I
don't know nobody knows with their Romeo
or not I mean nobody left this uh
disadvantage you know nobody went home
pissed off you know what I'm saying you
know wanting a refund right yeah nobody
wants a refunds right so after my mom
died and years later
I got a steady girlfriend I noticed that
it was down to a minute
I have no reason to lie to your doctor
but I'm not trying to be funny I mean my
ejaculate come with a minute and a half
it's open like it's over and sometimes
I'm breathing heavy and sometimes I even
get dizzy and sometimes I can't have sex
in the morning because I get really like
if it's super early and I get warmed up
so the other day you said that sometimes
your body goes into shock and your
breathing changes I didn't notice that I
was maybe
20. you know now I'm 50. I can't believe
I knocked my wife up
because these are the reasons why they
don't break it down but we're family
here does breathing affect your sex
breathing absolutely Tantra is based in
breathing when you think people talk
about tantric sex tantric sex you know
what does that mean Tantra in breathing
it's the same thing so think about this
in class we talked about pelvic floor
and people kind of laugh sometimes when
they think why are we talking about the
bottom of our body why are we talking
about all the muscles between your legs
and your thighs and your glutes and your
lower abs what does that have to do with
breathing they think breathing happens
all the way up you know by their
shoulders top of the chest and the fact
is that your pelvic floor is involved
you can take a better breath and this is
the breathing through your balls that I
talk about sometimes so if you inhale
and you relax your pelvic floor and
again I'm going to actually go into
detail if I talk about pelvic floor it's
the 20 muscles that are in the bottom
part of your body and the the very uh
specific pelvic floor is your bicycle
seat so all those muscles that hit the
bicycle seat that's your pelvic floor as
well so if you strengthen those muscles
you're going to strengthen your erection
you're going to strengthen being able to
last longer in bed
so that's why I say when you exhale and
you squeeze your lower abs and you
squeeze your whole body go ahead and
squeeze your pelvic floor too and by
Squeeze I mean this is what you can try
stopping the stream of urine Midstream
that's using some of your pelvic floor
muscles most of them not all of them or
if you're trying not to pass gas and you
squeeze those are kind of your pelvic
floor muscles as well it's not all your
glutes if you're squeezing your glutes
that's not your pelvic floor but if you
work out those muscles by squeezing on
the exhale which is breathing through
your balls everything that has to do
with sex is going to get better for men
and for women
so you're doing kegels pretty much
yeah
so the takeaway with that is on the
inhale relax your pelvic floor relax
your hips relax your butt okay that's a
reverse Kegel on the exhale squeeze your
belly squeeze your body and actually
squeeze the muscles on the bottom part
of your body the ones that hit the
bicycle seat so you squeeze those and
you let them go and you do that often
when you breathe letting go and
squeezing and letting go and you're
going to have a better erection if
you're a man you're going to be able to
stay hard longer and for a woman you're
also going to be able to have better
orgasms yeah
crazy but true right and you're
oxygenating and all those other things
it's a really good multitask
right now everybody's squeezing right
now I can tell I can tell I'm looking at
yourself
yeah it's just really weird to put all
the pieces together
that's the problem I've been having the
last few days not really it's when my
mind goes away and I start and then I go
what the [__] am I doing I'm I'm
breathing out but my stomach's going the
wrong [__] Direction but I do know
this one thing and I'm a very honest
person I do notice that on all my
exhales my stomach can't go all the way
in because of the amount of fat now
where is your diaphragm exactly here
okay so diaphragm let's do this so you
put your fingers up by your sternum that
little Notch right there all right and
then you walk them around and everybody
should do this go ahead and walk them
around that front rib and see if you can
stick your fingers underneath that front
rib and kind of give it a little tug
yeah okay so tug it out a little bit now
your ribs are attached to your sternum
like handles on a pail and they should
come out horizontally when you inhale
and they should squeeze together and
your body should get narrower on the
exhale keep your fingers going around
that rib around the side you're going to
hit that floating rib once you get to
the side keep going
now if you get your fingers and have
them go all the way to your back yeah
okay but imagine them going all the way
to your back so your diaphragm is
attached all the way around that bottom
rib it's a huge muscle the size of a you
know medium-sized pizza right in the
middle of your body and it's the
Enterprise that's a really important
muscle to have it's smack in the middle
of your body and leave for instance here
is not using his diaphragm because he
doesn't know how to yet he's using his
shoulder still but right now when you
inhale and you let your body relax and
expand and you exhale and you squeeze it
that's you using your diaphragm
so you're doing it
good stuff
oh
mayday mayday mayday they're coming to
get me this is very the the seminar I
left there
first off the next day I woke up and my
head felt different mmm my head felt I
don't drink I don't smoke you know I
smoke a few numbers but my head felt
different
like something different that happened
and then the next day I felt my back
because the next day I went at it pretty
hard and I Rewritten the beginning and I
made some notes and I did so many
exercises and I remembered a few things
and I remember one of the exercises I
could see that my shoulders were moving
too much so I stopped doing the
exercises until next week when I go to
now what's the difference between two
and warriors I gotta actually remind you
that you also you you also had a nice
poop right because yes ma'am yeah that's
the clinical word that's the clinical
word for that hey you know given how
constipated we all are as a country you
got to celebrate a good poop when you
have one right so the breathing even
helps to poop absolutely will help to
digestion it helps a digestion so
everything gets better because think
about this actually Lee's thinking what
does hell what does that is that if your
diaphragm is pushing down on your on
your organs right they're all getting a
massage so if you have acid reflux it's
going to help with that constipation
irritable bowel but if you breathe with
your shoulders nada nothing so that's
why you got to learn to breathe with the
middle part of your body but uh okay so
the advance you can't go straight to the
Advance without taking the beginning
class it's just you have all that
information has to sink in but the
advance we actually when it's a jiu
jitsu class is that we do different
types of breathing in your body so we do
a lateral breath we do a back breath we
do a lower body breath and upper body
breath but in different positions
because Jiu Jitsu is super interesting
in that you are always in a compromised
position pretty much in any other sport
you're in an uncomfortable position
sometimes but introduce you you're
always going to be in a position that's
awkward it's just the nature of the
sport I'm so fat that this times I'm on
top of you and I can't [__] breathe
that's when you know you're a fat [__]
when I'm on copying side control and I'm
having a [__] hard time breathing and
I ain't even moving I'm holding on to
you like you're a [__] rope and
there's an earthquake against them I
ain't going nowhere I'm holding on to
your neck if the Earth tips over you
know I'm taking it that's them I'm
amazing that they told me you know when
you passed a guard breathe and catch
your breath and sometimes because you
know you get caught up or they're
holding your ghee you know when they
hold you again you can't move and you
know in my world I'm just to keep
breathing you just keep breathing you
know just keep breathing keep breathing
but once you pass the guard you I would
lay down just to catch my breath and
sometimes it was worse
well one thing is that if you're
breathing in a dysfunctional way if
you're breathing using your shoulders
that's a teeny tiny breath so if you're
prone to take a teeny tiny breath when
you have friction of the other person or
the mat on you it's not gonna work
so that lower body breath is a much more
efficient breath that's why I like
working with athletes is that you take a
breath through the lower part of your
body using your diaphragm that's worth
six breaths on top so you want to be
able to breathe efficiently when you
only have a couple seconds to catch your
breath
so you know in the like you asked in the
advanced class we take all the exercises
we did in the first class and then we
make them a lot harder so that they
really become challenging so we do them
in inversions we do all those breaths
that we did upside down so that's what
we got coming up on uh on Saturday
is that we're doing them upside down
we're doing them in all different
positions and then we do a lot yeah yeah
yeah yeah
I hope you got some [__] sumo
wrestlers there we got some I'll bring
some to class we do them in different
ways and then we talk specifically about
fighting so
um center of gravity you know you want
to breathe in a way that lowers your
center of gravity you want to breathe in
a way that helps you tolerate pain
um smothering so we get a little bit
more specific which is nice which is
nice if it's just juice Jutsu then we
just talk about Jiu Jitsu which is nice
if it's people from all different
fighting backgrounds that when you can
use examples from all different fighting
backgrounds but
um you know like we started talking
about is that if you're stacked or neon
you can't breathe well how are you going
to breathe when you were in those two
positions that are really difficult to
breathe in and that's you know some of
the things that we do I love talking
about fighting and breathing I can do it
all day well a lot of times like did you
see that Sage Northcutt fight a few
months ago where he he tapped but it
wasn't really in but he said later on he
had like a flu and couldn't breathe so
do you do you work with Fighters then
click change their entire careers if
they're not like gassing out all the
time you know what I have
had was a brown belt Gracie brown belt
and he had plateaued and he would gas
while he was fighting and he would also
get very nervous so he came to me
because he wanted to get his black belt
and he did he worked like a fiend and he
got his black belt because those were
the two things that were holding him
back and thankfully those were the his
technique was amazing he was super
talented but you know he would run out
of energy and he would get nervous so
that's perfect for breathing I got him
over those two things now how about
nerves well if you're breathing upper
body breath
are you talking about nerves while
you're fighting or before
listen fighting in comedy before you go
on stage
same fear okay you know I tell people
all the time that I wear long shirts I
want them shirts because I hate
traveling along the way
smuggle on weed or something more
important than five pound my underwear
you know if I pan my underwear can feed
a [__] Village you know what I'm
saying so sometimes on a Saturday you
work out you jump in a pool and you
forget to put underwear and you forget
to take your underwear off before you
jump in the pool sometimes so I actually
had my underwear counted for four days
so Saturday on stage I have to go on
stage
and sometimes I paint my pants from the
anxiety before I go on stage and it's
the same fear for that one minute and a
half I talk and it makes you a good
fighter or a comedian or a good jujitsu
guy that's what we don't we have to just
use it yeah it's very weird and I know
how to do it and stand up yeah I'm the
master
I forced myself to once I hit that foot
my goal is to touch that mic as quick as
I can so whatever fear I have in my
stomach I've already learned how to get
it out to the microphone it goes out
their laughter comes back in and feeds
me and we got a tennis match going
now we've got an energy tennis match
going I haven't figured out how to
transform that into jujitsu
kettlebells now with weights I could in
my mind take the rack off exhale
correct
inhale
exhale on the way up inhale exhale I
know this going in now when I'm walking
on the treadmill
from a systemic eye that we had on the
show the problem was the heat in the
room at the other place messed up the
tape and I'm going to call him and get
it on I get get him back on the podcast
he spoke about
because there's a jiu jitsu School in
Hollywood
in Beverly Hills and they have a
systemic school it's a system a Jujitsu
school with tahiga Machado and I forget
whether he's a great guy this guy no I
mean I smoke too much but
one time him and I were speaking and he
goes this is what I want you to do just
go for a walk in the park
and I want you to start with two steps I
want you I'm going to Exhale on two
inhale until exhale into and go to three
and four and then five and six and he
was telling me what he could do with my
mind almost [__] blew up
so when you meant mentioned to stamina
in your system you know whatever whether
it's a couple of warm-ups what I'm gonna
do now is
the next
[__] eight months I'm gonna do all
these warm-up exercises as part of my
warm-up for either kettlebells or Jiu
Jitsu or lifting I'm gonna do the side
stretches the breathing the weights I'm
gonna put a [__] tank on my [__]
stomach you understand me I'm a police I
want Lee to put his head in my stomach
and lift his feet up like a somersault
we're gonna be podcast D Soleil you and
I you understand me I'll do it but I
will pay to see that um
because I know the breathing exercises
already helped me in Jiu-Jitsu today a
little bit not that I submitted anybody
anything but I had more energy I moved a
little bit more and I focused on the
exhale beautiful I focused on the exhale
all the way to the end
and it did lower a little bit of the
anxiety good it should it should because
neurologically it puts you in a lower
state of anxiety so yeah
yep yeah your nervous system and we
talked about this in classes your
nervous system hears be in fight inflate
when you breathe with your shoulders so
you can't be anything but anxious when
you breathe with an upper body breath so
when I'm working with uh you know I
actually had a particular SWAT guy who
was uh he was having panic attacks in
the truck and uh I had to teach him how
to breathe with a lower body breath and
then talk to himself to pull himself
down to calm himself down so it's that
lower body breath so that that makes you
feel better your neurological system
then you can talk to yourself but you
can't talk to yourself and still be
telling your body neurologically to be
calmed down because it's not going to
listen
even as
uh you'll see The Godfather
before he goes to shoot salazzo at the
restaurant
you know that's why he's such a great
director the guy I forget what his name
is Francis
he he you hear a train stopping now
you're a sweetheart of a human being I'm
telling you this from experience before
you do something bad
to that level and then I did a lot of
things in that level
your body unless you're a [__]
psychopath which I think it doesn't
happen the psychopath
but it happened to me I know whenever I
would do something bad
the adrenaline rush combined with your
breath gets taken away it's like
if I knew for example right now that Lee
and you had twenty thousand dollars in
cash here and a kilo blow
and my friend dropped me off on the
corner by the cemetery there
by the time he dropped me off by the
time I crossed the street
I would be breathing so hard just
thinking about it telling you to store
me
my breath has uh risen just thinking
about it because I know what I have to
do it I kicked that [__] gate down
like zombo I either got to kick that
door down or shoot it or welt or jump up
here and get you know the only out here
where the [__] are you guys gonna go you
have to jump off the balcony and get
around the building so by the time I
jump up here I got a gun to the door
it's over I gotta get through here get
the gun you know what's going through my
[__] head
and I used to control that don't ask me
how I did there was no book named
[__] breathe
1882 there was no book named [__]
breathe
it was when I get in the car
it was like I had just run 22 miles
like you felt that worn out that that
time that much adrenaline and now in
hindsight I know this from 30 years
experience but 20 years ago I didn't
know this stupidity how
that short period of time probably at
least starting to make noises that means
he's really [__] high once he starts
noises over here yeah
he gets too [__] high and he says
praying for his soul you can hear me
please please Jesus help me
please Jesus help me so it was really
weird you control that yeah and that's
what's happening to me in Jiu Jitsu and
every time I go to Jujitsu I go for two
more things to last a little longer on
top and breathe or to complete something
like you had that completed a sweep when
I was really tired and I tapped the guys
come on you had me I go I'm done I'm
good I did two rounds in this whatever I
swept you and uh I like when I uh
when somebody's on top of me and I last
a little longer because my anxiety
levels I learned how to create a frame
stay there hold them down until I can
get them hopefully if they pull away I
try to escape you know I've learned all
these little things which is giving me
more confidence
so uh these are the little things I'm
working on for my breathing just on my
breathing I love that and because
you've learned in a way I teach in a
quantifiable way and that's what I like
you got this number and you're going to
get to this number and then you're going
to get to this number so it's all about
these little steps or big ones because I
could see you taking big ones but it's
all about steps to get bigger and uh and
you're doing them you already
automatically go to about 30 seconds I
want 45. I'm at a minute I want two
minutes well the breath hold is still a
little difficult don't worry about the
breath hold the first time it still gets
stuck yeah and the second time I have to
look away
I have to look away and focus and not
have the clock around me and I've been
hitting like 34 or 32. that's fine I
don't want you practicing the breath
holds they're not that big of a deal
more than anything I want you breathing
through your nose because you know that
the nose breathing is super important
we're gonna get your nose better you
know one of my biggest fears the breath
is there's an earthquake something I
gotta run with my daughter
and she's 40 pounds and all I could do
is run a half a [__] block and
Godzilla is behind me with 22 Japanese
guys in a [__] drum
so every morning when I walk into school
I try to last a little longer and I pick
her up and I just walk with her and I
just focus on my breathing I don't focus
on how heavy she is or how pretty she is
or how nicer hair looks I focus on my
breathing you know my exhale my exhales
I've been working on it because it
[__] petrifies me no you got it and
because we're putting upside down on
Saturday so upside down
can you please take a picture of it I
will take a picture do I get to hold
myself oh I'm not gonna even tell you
because yeah yeah it's gonna be a
surprise but you know you brought
something up that's important which is
the endurance in sports if you can get
your breathing muscles to be stronger
then you don't gas you know then you
don't have this feeling of not being
able to of losing motivation of losing
focus so those breathing muscles I mean
yeah we're getting you to breathe the
right way through the right orifice but
a lot of it is strengthening your
muscles it's not you know it's not brain
surgery it's making sure your
intercostals your obliques your abs your
pelvic floor your diaphragm are all
working just like any other muscle you
want to be stronger period
so that's a little sore in the morning
that you get which is good I want you to
be sore I want you to have that feeling
of why my my middle of my body is sore
that's weird or I'm breathing in my back
I feel it in my back that's why well
Sunday
the seminar was Saturday and Sunday and
Monday nothing happened with my back
only something in class when you made a
stretch a certain way but Tuesday I was
walking Mercy to school
and I was focusing on my breathing I
didn't I didn't [__] get my wife
started in no conversation I just walked
three feet ahead of him making believe I
was thinking about something and I
really focused on my breathing
and at the light
I guess when I had a stop I could feel
my back moving around my little fat and
I was like okay we're getting somewhere
I'm bringing that to life you know what
I'm saying we're getting somewhere so
and you used to breathe that way I mean
one of the reasons why it's not that
hard or it makes sense anyway is because
you used to breathe this way when you
were little it was a long time ago but
you used to breathe this way and now I
could make my body remember your body
can remember by over exaggerating the
movements yeah because it's kind of
testing you to see are you gonna let me
breathe this way because it wants to
your body the only reason God put the
diaphragm in the very middle of your
body that huge muscle very center of
your body right below your heart so you
could breathe with it right and you
haven't been at all and now it's sort of
going can I use can I work are you gonna
let me do this for real so it's sort of
seeing if you're okay and you're really
going to use it or you're going to go
back to shoulder breathing and make it
not do anything again so yeah it's just
your body checking you to see like are
you really are we really going to work
together now because when you breathe
with your diaphragm when you read the
right way your whole body is working
together and you should get some kind of
a feeling of that of like I feel like my
whole body is inhaling and exhaling
I feel like I feel more unified in some
way
maybe not right away but see if it comes
to you
a bad [__] yeah
we'll ask you some more questions we'll
get you out of here my main man James
Wilson always emailing me little Jiu
Jitsu drills he sent me a Kettlebell
workout this is what's good about this
health thing that everybody kicks in a
little bit my man Alex Costino and [__]
Dax Z not Rob G the octopus fire goddess
bet Paul Savage Sean scooter Brandon Lee
no Brandy Lee
my girl from Minneapolis and my main man
and his dad bob la Lingus
one of you [__] nuts so what so
you do the uh breathing for warriors too
this Saturday now when you go to New
York is there a breathing for warriors
one yes we have uh breathing for
warriors one is
end of May
and then we've got to teach your
training
which is uh gonna be either the end of
May or the beginning of June which is
exciting because I've had and actually
that was not my idea I've had so many
people who train or who are physical
therapists say can I learn this how do I
learn this I want to be able to teach
this to my clients my patients so the
teacher training is going to be fun and
I love teaching I mean you give me a
group of people that are interested in
anatomy and psychology and you know I'm
in heaven it's weird because enthusiasm
breeds enthusiasm
and uh I'm not a big [__] seminar guy
I wouldn't make this was very important
to me because I almost quit doing
Jujitsu because of this because every
time I was going to jujitsu
you know I thought I was gonna die of a
heart attack
but I kept going more and more I'm just
working on my breathing working on my
breathing if it was one more hip Escape
don't worry about it as long as you
breathe yourself out of there
so this was a big decision of whether or
not I was going to quit Jiu-Jitsu never
in horror stories that one there's a guy
at Higgin machado's that rolled one down
I know he left class he sat on my way
home his left arm started hurting
white tone to drive himself to the
hospital they did a double bypass they
put balloons in his leg and [__] and
he's back doing Jiu Jitsu you know good
for him You've Gotta Love The Valor but
I don't want to be what I'm saying so
I'm trying to be careful I know the one
answers like I just gotta drop 100
[__] pounds but that's easier said
than done and I gotta tell you
when I first attacked this diet thing
it had to be when I was about 45 or 46
when I cleaned up
double heart again
uh
because I walk a lot now I force myself
to walk I walk to the weed store now
I walked the baby to school you know if
I have a chance to walk I walk to the
office you know and so let's just work
everything and I could tell there's no
ice cream in my house my wife gets
[__] ice cream sometime but you get
it from the Mexican ice cream man he
shows up at 6 30. the little cones are
delicious but besides that I'm not like
a sweet guy anything like that if I eat
marijuana when you eat marijuana
it's a tough [__] devil if I can beat
when I smoked marijuana I don't even
need to eat it's eating marijuana that
if I stay up past 11 40 the refrigerator
is done you know what I'm saying now
I've dropped a weight I know I burned up
secondary calories I avoid chips I try
to avoid french fries only when this
[__] demon over here takes her to a
place called Stout
horrible influence I apologize they got
onion rings with horseradish you know oh
my God you just find that thick and the
burgers are delicious and I'm not even a
cheeseburger dude so and they're open
late which is great [__] so I'm a I'm a
burger without the bun type of dude at
the house I love a little Burger without
the bun and the protein shakes and the
drinks you're trying to get me to like I
said I drank I tried that green drink
with a lot of apples oh my God have the
book grapes in next time you should put
everything sugar because healthy fish
let me tell you something this [__]
thing tasted so bad I can't do it
anymore it's like I told my wife I go
you know people have to understand that
20 you still listen I I didn't eat food
she thought I was 26 and I [__] love
sushi today but they caught me early I
knew at [__] nine that cauliflower
wasn't for me I knew it nine then
broccoli was not for me there is no
better dish looking wise eyeball than
broccoli with cheese on top especially
when you smoke 10 [__] joints and
you're a hungry kid nothing looks better
none of that [__] has ever appealed to
me tofu I wouldn't eat [__] tofu if
that was the only food left on Earth I'd
rather starve I'd rather rake up in
Africa with that kiwi mosquito bite me
or some [__] like that then eat that
[__] look at the shape of this
[__] zombie you'd rather wake up in
Africa [__] eat that
tofu [__] I mean you know I'm doing a
little bit extreme the dog I'm telling
you right now I take it out of my hot
and sour soup okay I don't [__] around I
don't even I don't even put my I don't
even taste time sour soup until all the
tofu was out of there why what is it
gonna do to you because it just it
destroys me the texture would [__]
kill me the texture kills me all that
[__] kills me if I would have liked it I
would have liked it a long time and
trust me there's enough I'm a fat [__]
there's not that many foods out there
that I would but like it goes down in
like two seconds
on my table you understand me but I like
hot and sour soup but I have a job to
take it out of there myself
so that's what I do there's certain
things I can't eat Dr police I just
can't do
and I've tried just breathe just you
know what I ate today what spinach oh
like I could eat spinach but it's got to
be made a certain way yeah it's got to
be doped up heavy duty garlic fresh
garlic cut it thin a little butter and
then throw the spinach in there mix it
up nice all right you get some black
bean rubbish with some uh some whatever
I want to listen man I went to my today
I had a meeting at three and the people
wanted to take me to eat lunch first I
said all right let's go eat lunch I put
a suit on they took me to a nice place
white people I went in there and I got
everybody was eating steaks like
cannibals what do you think I ate I had
a nice piece of salmon with a a bean
hash with spinach I didn't touch the
bread and I had the [__] and I had
the chopped spinach with anchovies
because what'd you drink water and iced
tea beautiful and you didn't touch the
Bread Basket eight plus eight plus yeah
yeah we think you're dealing with so
[__] obviously I'm trying to pick up
the heat here and it's tough I did take
a spoonful of the chocolate mousse I
know that's okay now
yeah no no that's okay what did you do
from 11 to 12 today you deserve a little
[__] eat the flan eat the flan no I
won't eat it I know I know no it's from
that movie remember eat the flan what
movie uh real women have curves I don't
remember yeah you got to see that with
America let me tell you something if you
eat [__] flounder I'm a lot of
[__] terms there's two flies okay
there's the flan you could eat at your
[__] friends restaurant that's
tremendous you you have an espresso and
everybody Giggles somebody might go home
and smile and fought one of those almond
farts from the flan or you go to a real
Cuban's house where they make it with
condensed milk yup and it weighs 22
[__] pounds for a tray it's like a
lasagna and you're like this is supposed
to be a dessert and you can't figure out
why until you eat it and you sit there
and your body composition changes I want
to see you lick one of those [__]
things after you eat a piece of flying
with things it's black it turns black my
mom does not cook but she makes fun they
[__] love Cubans will make a flan
that'll kill you with the egg yolks I
mean everything sometimes that's how I
like I like the coconut but that'll kill
you crazy it's heavy too you'll get a
piece of food it's really heavy it's too
heavy there's like two it's two pounds
for a slice yeah and because if that
portals I don't know if it's Cuban
though but Tres Leches is that Cuban or
no is that Mexican I think that's more
Mexican okay but that's crazy too like
just Cubans have a great dessert that I
loved and my mother loved and I gotta
say it was probably I hate to say this
God but it was probably a little
contributing practice to a heart attack
there's a dish called Matia
and it's a custard
but it's poured over Entenmann's pound
cake
I know with cinnamon and you put it in
the freezer and it gets hard then you
pull it on either while you're watching
The Honeymooners oh my God that sounds
amazing that's the end of the [__]
show right there you understand me
that's how good that is there's one
place that makes it just like my mother
with that and I'm not I wouldn't even
tell nobody else I'm telling you
[__] because my girl's here
what do you live in New York uh I'm on
the upper west side you have Cuba before
he's not by you no I gotta go up a
little further you gotta go up bike yeah
but a couple blocks yeah you gotta I got
Caridad
okay it's not like you know it's not
perfect I like Cafe Con Leche yeah
16th and 8th Avenue they're from but
they're yeah they're Puerto Rican
they're from uh
no no no Victor's Cafe yeah uh you know
there's not there's uh this place it is
it's up on 136th that's you just have to
go uptown not in my immediate
neighborhood we just got a lot of bagels
we got bagels and locks yeah because it
gets in my [__] world you know
what I'm saying
stop it uh Dr Bliss thank you very much
for coming on I just want people to know
you know a lot of people who go to jiu
jitsu or black but I mean people always
hit me up like it's like James Wilson he
sends me exercises he sent me something
called uh the goat bag blaster for
cardios you got a kettlebell it's only
and you pick it up what's it called when
you hold the red hailing you do a squat
um
whatever the [__] it is
I love those you do five of those and
then you turn it over and you listen to
this you put this in your diaphragm the
bottom of the ball and you spread your
legs just a little bit don't still
shoulder and you bend over instead of
doing swings and strengthening you back
that way to help with your to help with
your uh hip escapes it it does something
to your hip joints it makes them a
little stronger I did that's the work I
did yeah that this I do some Turkish Get
ups with my shoe because my shoulder is
kind of loose yeah I'll do some cleans
I'll do some one-arch swings that's
squats and that's the end of that she
does a yoga class for jiu jitsu
specifically yoga for jujitis Aaron does
it at Dynamics here in L.A yeah she did
something at 10 planning no I think she
I mean she might do the class there as
well right yeah we'll pull her in here
and ask but it's a yoga for jiu jitsu
class okay we know and they can go to
Dynamics yeah and that's Anthony
that's a great place great place and
I'll be back there with you sadly yeah
thank you very much
just to know that our acidic level was
okay
your acidic level was perfect now and I
mean this isn't
what typical podcast but I thought you
were so interesting and so open up uh
can you tell us more about your book
real quick yeah it's called breathe I
mean and and anybody who emails me and
says I heard about you from the podcast
I will send you a book so just write to
me give me your address I'll send you a
book
um it gives you the basics that we learn
in class it's not as good as class of
course but it'll definitely give you the
basics and
um I'm teaching all over the place and
if you want me to come teach wherever
you live it's just about setting up
setting up a class and I'll come over
not a problem
when you look at your apartment okay
because I think you're as interesting as
[__] and I think that you should alert
more people this thing you're doing
because I tell you man
listen Linda Skinner's got a book out I
read four pages a day I've been reading
the book for two [__] months I read
four or five pages a day not because I
don't like when it's kind of because I
got a lot on my plate I've read your
book three days in a row like 10 pages
oh my God so there's something in there
especially for me because this is a big
fear of mine man so thank you for uh you
know tell me about your seminar for
staying on top of me and I'm going back
Saturday to get [__] part two of
Warriors yeah and even if I get five
seconds more cardio and I get to just
keep working on it you want me to do in
the beginning and after class or just
the beginning
often as possible right now like right
now when your body's learning this if
you can do it twice a day and then every
single time because I see you you're
reminding yourself you're sitting here
and every once in a while you'll you'll
do an exercise or two which is perfect
because right now your body's kind of
open to uh you know learn something new
so as often as possible right now
because the more you do it uh the more
it's gonna sink in and you're gonna
click over and it's going to become
natural
okay yeah thank you beautiful thank you
thank you and let me talk to you about
something you savage is here
real quick don't forget as usual on it
than my people they take care of us I
just brought in some
where is it over there I don't know who
cares it's someone it's some uh good
stuff what is it called Alpha Brain
Alpha Brain the instant stuff uh I got
some sent to me tremendous if you do a
lot of flying and you get that jet lag
at the end as usual you know me you got
me with shroom Tech that's as good as it
gets in my world you get a little bit
more endurance you know when you leave
there sometimes you think you're winded
but you're really not you just left
because you thought it was time to leave
and that's what shroom Tech sport does
you have shroom Tech immune again if you
fly and getting people breathing in your
[__] neck and then you go home and
you cough what good is it so you need
some shoe Tech uh immune on it has a
great selection and all different stuff
do me a favor go to honored.com take a
look at what they got from the MCT oil
to the to the shroom Tech to the what
else the testosterone booster
testosterone boost Alpha Brain with 100
money back then the old J wave protein
whey protein which you're almost [__]
done with already it's delicious it's
delicious listen just go to honor.com
put everything in a cart
Preston Church c-h-u-r-c-h
and get 10 off 10 off the top right off
and it gets delivered
to your goddamn door who's better than
you huh you don't have to leave the
[__] house you get Chinese delivered
you get on it delivered
what else
also this is one of my favorites I've
gotten some great little reviews on this
you know you got smart cars smartphones
Smart Homes Technology has made
everything smart but losing your stuff
still makes Smart people feel really
stupid tracker makes losing things a
thing of the past tracker is a coin size
device that locates misplaced Keys
wallets bags computers anything in
seconds just pair tracker to the
smartphone attach it to anything and
find it's precise I mean precise
location with the top of a button it's
that easy boom lose your phone press the
button on tracker and your phone rings
even if it's on silent with over 1.5
million devices tractor has the largest
crowd GPS Network in the world so your
lost items show up on a map even if it's
miles away never lose anything again
with tracker listeners of this show get
a special discount of 30 off your entire
order again 30 off your entire order go
to the take t h e tracker.com and enter
promo code Church [__] again the
t-h-e-tracker.com and that's the promo
code Church the hardest thing you'll
ever have to find is their website go to
tracker.com right now on tracker.com go
to ztracker.com go to see
go to the tracker.com right now and
enter promo code church for 30 off your
entire order again that's the
tracker.com promo code church I want to
thank tracker I want to thank on it I
want to thank Dr Balise I want to thank
my main man Lisa yet I want to thank
staff one I want to thank everybody for
being nice people for listening to the
show tonight
and have a good weekend we'll be back
Monday ready to [__] rock and roll
don't forget
next Thursday night I'm in Buffalo
[__] New York straight up at
Helium Comedy Club next Thursday night
and the week after that I'm in
Indianapolis Dr police if you want to
stop by we'll do some [__] breathing
exercises in Indianapolis you know what
I'm saying
and that's it what are you doing this
weekend Tarzan mama coming over
together
he was all Panic actually
panicking you're still not wearing the
robe
she went there the [__] is wrong with
you still walking around with your
physique with long boxer shorts on and
[__] when you wear the Rope you know it
does
forget that it makes you [__]
mysterious they don't know what you're
packing under there because you know
it's been three years she knows exactly
what I'm about you gotta show up with
different costumes Friday night you're a
bull rider Saturday you're a [__]
exorcism and they all wear robes no with
different outfits she thinks it's a
different person you talk in different
languages
you gotta keep it interesting you got
that three year mark if not it goes sour
I don't even have a book worth I don't
even have a relationship on books this
is my name this is my new vention
okay you gotta get a cape and like a
Tarzan mask for how like how many does
it can't rotate them no you gotta wear
the same thing every night no dumb you
gotta rotate them no but like okay so
every week you're a [__] surprise
right all right but like let's say I'm a
cowboy right right
do I have an ongoing story like three
months down the road do I like come back
and like listen you know what whatever
your imagination let's loose whatever
makes Paula happy if she wants it to be
an ongoing story like you come to town
every three months yeah that's what I
think smack around throw it to the
kitchen table and then make love to it
and leave that works
then you come back have like a doctor
you hemender and heal and tell her you
love it sing him a song turn around
every now and then I feel a little and
then you [__] leave and you come back
as Charles Bronson you leave money on
this counter take it I'm not a [__]
you know what I'm saying you gotta play
I don't know I don't do that [__] you
know man
with nothing but skin and work boots on
when you show up with a cape we're
working with the grandma blow you're
running a [__] game you know what I'm
saying did he tied together and like run
did I what did you like run around with
a cape I would do a little dance you
know how I do you just don't show up
with your dick in your hand you gotta
have a little cape and do a little dance
women like to dance that's how you
hypnotize how use your [__] brainly
we'll talk about this off here we'll be
back Monday eight o'clock and next
Wednesday I love you guys with all my
heart Buffalo get your [__] together
again I'd like to thank Dr Belize is
there a website
or the breathing class
you'll be a website I do at
leastsion.com and I just did a great
episode of life in neutral with Johnny
Rock we told you it was great that
somebody raid it yeah the New York Times
contact new [__] sure don't be
lying this [__] the what is it uh no
he's got a good show Lisa yeah at least
I had in this case I've known him from
the onion they work really hard
stay black
this show is brought to you by tracker
never lose anything again with tracker
go to the tracker doc listeners to this
show get a special 30 discount off their
entire order go to the tracker.com
t-h-e-tracker.com enter promo code
Church
and go to audit.com Andy's promo code
Church to get 10 off all the good
optimization products like Alpha Brain
and new mood
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign